alexandre kateb bonjour merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin on se
dirige donc vers une prolongation de
l'accord de réduction de production
quels sont les intérêts qui s'affrontent
autour de la table on le rappelle un lot
paie plus avec donc 24 24 pays oui
bonjour alors effectivement l'opep c'est
une organisation qui n'est pas forcément
à 13 unis puisque il y à la fois des
pays donc qui sont très dépendants du
cours du pétrole et d'autres pays qui
finalement peuvent supporter un prix du
pétrole bas pendant une longue période
notamment des pays comme les émirats par
exemple mais dans l'ensemble en fait le
vrai problème c'est entre l'opep et les
autres pays comme la russie qui ont des
intérêts encore plus divergents et qui
en fait ne sont pas tout à fait sur la
même longueur d'onde
puisque la russie pense que si on décale
davantage encore
c'est là la lave la baisse des des
réductions de production en fait ça va
plutôt avantager les producteurs de
pétrole américains de pétrole de schiste
et donc qu'on fait ça aura un impact nul
sur le marché devant les états unis ne
ne sont pas membres de l'opep
il ne fait plus on voit la future
décision de l'organisation de l'opep sur
intel liées au marché de l'or noir
américain oui alors les états unis ne
sont pas à vendre mais il joue
évidemment un rôle éminent aujourd'hui
dans l'équilibré du marché à travers
justement ces producteurs de pétrole de
schiste je rappelle que les états unis
sont devenus aujourd'hui le premier
producteur de pétrole au monde à parité
avec l'arabie saoudite et la russie et
dans et que aux états unis il n'y a
aucun à aucune restriction en fait sur
la production est ce qu'on a vu
récemment c'est que alors qu'on
assistait à une chute du nombre de puits
de pétrole
depuis la crise en fait depuis quelques
semaines on voit qu'il ya un
retournement à ce niveau-là et qu' il ya
de nouveaux puits de pétrole qui étaient
gelés et qui sont remis en activité ce
qui montre qui a un vrai analyse de la
demande donc qui revient aux états unis
et qui profite à ses producteurs
américains en premier moins de 7 7
millions de barils sur 90 à 100 millions
barils jour en temps normal quelles
conséquences économiques
les conséquences économiques
c'est que évidemment il ya des pays de
l'opep qui ont du mal à boucler leur
budget et qu'ils ont même des déficits
de la balance commerciale je pense
notamment à des petits producteurs comme
l'algérie qui est très pénalisée par un
prix du pétrole qui reste relativement
bas et et par une production qui
elle-même tend à diminuer et donc
l'algérie en fait par exemple aurait
intérêt à un maintien des restrictions
pour faire monter davantage le prix du
pétrole mais d'autres pays évidemment ne
sont pas du même avis et pluton granger
des recettes supplémentaires par l'effet
volume et quelles sont les dates estimé
un retour à la normale alors selon ce
toutou l'un dépend en fait de
l'évolution de la demande mondiale de
pétrole qui est elle même conditionné à
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire de
du déploiement des vaccins notamment les
campagnes de vaccination qui vont avoir
lieu et de la confiance
retrouvez des consommateurs qui vont du
coup circuler davantage
je rappelle que le transport est la
première source de consommation du
pétrole et donc la situation dans le
secteur du transport est véritablement
l'élément je dirais le plus déterminant
pour juger de la demande mondiale de
pétrole
merci alexandre kateb d'avoir répondu à
la question je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste consultant international et
fondateur du site de multipolarité
report